I think once people see what a real
tintype looks like as opposed to you
know a filter on a on a camera phone
they'll realize that there's just no
comparison my name is Patrick Demings
and I'm a portrait photographer I
specialize in using a process from the
1860s called wet plate collodion or
tintype I shoot large format and I use a
camera that's very durable it was made
in the 1950s by a company called Calumet
a lot of people called the Big Green
Monster because it's very heavy from
beginning to end the tintype process
involves taking a piece of aluminum of
black aluminum and you pour a collodion
suspension over that plate after you
poured your collodion you take that
still wet plate and you dunk it into a
bath of silver nitrate silver nitrate is
going to create a reaction with the
collodion and the salts suspended in
that collodion to make the silver
light-sensitive and then you load that
film into the back of the camera pull up
the dark slide and shoot
once it's exposed you'll have this
latent image on the back of that metal
the silvers been exposed to light
there's an image there it just needs to
be revealed by the development process
you want to stop the development process
just as you start seeing some details in
the shadow areas and then you have an
image you can take out into the light
and fix as the the fixer washes away all
the the unexposed silver their positive
image emerges out of that cloud and when
they see it for the first time it's just
magical it's amazing
your eyes only see the visible spectrum
of light of ROYGBIV but wet-plate is
shifted is shifted towards ultraviolet
so it sees some details in our faces and
in landscapes that we can't even see
ourselves you know that's why sometimes
people notice freckles in their faces or
little scars that they forgot they had
you know you're taking right alekhya ler
silver and creating an image with it it
really is a dance of silver and light
that makes just an unbelievable image on
that piece of metal